renowned physicist Stephen Hawking has
died at the age of 76 but his
contributions to humanity will live on
forever
including what is arguably his life's
most important work his appearances on
The Simpsons news of the late scientists
passing inspired a number of tributes in
the entertainment world which Hawking
had an outsized influence on as a public
figure the author never restricted
himself to purely academic appearances
lending his likeness or voice to a
number of high-profile pop culture
projects outside of academia Hawking
appeared as himself on an episode of
Star Trek The Next Generation as well as
multiple episodes of The Simpsons a
Futurama and the Big Bang Theory I made
a boo-boo and I gave it Stephen Hawking
he also lent his voice a synthesized
program to the Pink Floyd albums the
division Bell and the endless river
after Hawking's death a Simpsons
showrunner Al Jean spoke to The
Hollywood Reporter about the experience
of arranging the professor's hilarious
first appearance on the series season 10
episode they saved Lisa's brain looking
for trouble
you found it gene explained what we
would do is send in the script and then
he would record it through his machine
so it was his voice his special audio
program he did come to the studio when
he was in America but he didn't ever go
to record over the course of his three
appearances on the show Hawking was
willing to go along with just about
everything the writers wanted him to say
except one thing in his first episode
that rubbed him the wrong way gene said
he did say at one point that he did not
want to be drunk on screen that was the
only note we got from him he didn't mind
having a beer with Homer at Moe's but
not more
the theory of a doughnut-shaped universe
this intriguing owner I may add to steal
it
Hawking's first appearance in which
Homer Simpson famously mistook him for
hustler magnate Larry Flynt came about
thanks to a personal connection
Hawking's daughter Lucy knew one of the
show's writers who wanted to plan an
episode involving him aside from the
drinking scene Hawking had no problems
with the way the long-running cartoon
series depicted him he said my treatment
and The Simpsons was always good
humoured I was depicted as a somewhat
surreal character with enormous powers
gene added that the reason he scripted
the late academic the way he did was he
saw him as a superstar in his own right
saying everyone wanted to get their
picture taken with him it was an honor
to be able to briefly interact with the
Albert Einstein of our time I still
can't get over it time for this heart of
light
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]